Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we are gonna take a look at
Daggerizing.
And by Daggerizing, obviously, it's an old word.
We're gonna use Dagger to build or augment
or enrich
pipelines and existing open source projects to see
if we can make their lives a little
bit easier. And today, we're taking a look
at a project called Cargo, and I have
the pleasure to be joined by a friend
and a maintainer,
Kat.
Hey. How are you?
You're on mute.
See, you had that music playing, and I
was, like, jamming you. And I was like,
I gotta mute mute this, and now I
look like a fool. No. I'm super excited
to be on with you. I know we've
kind of been
running in parallel craft paths across the interwebs,
and we finally actually get to do something.
So that's cool. Yeah. We we both seem
to like a lot of the same
technological
stuff. So now we get to sit down
and actually experiment and have some fun together,
which is awesome.
And don't think we we streamed once before,
right, when I was at Equinix, I think.
I it
maybe. I have to go look. I My
feelings aren't hurt. That's okay. It's not a
tear. I was so sorry. I
swear I will remember this one. Like, you
you had music for, like, custom lyrics with
card how'd you do that? That's so cool.
I have been experimenting with AI music, and
I'm gonna do some videos on it because
it's so freaking cool right now.
And it's so inexpensive
to do and so quick. I can't believe
it. But, yeah, that was a nice that
was the first time we've ever used AI
and AI opening music, and it was customized
for Dagger, Cargo, and Jew, which was awesome.
I thought so. Thank you. Okay.
Alright.
Look. For anyone who is not familiar with
you, can you give us a little bit
of a TLDR on who you are and
what you've been up to?
Good god. Okay. So TLDR
version. I
am a nerd on the interwebs and
nerding out with everyone on platform engineering and
DevOps, GitOps, all those fun ops y things.
Kind of climbed through the ranks a little
bit at a time professionally,
just going from being a Linux nerd to
actually getting to apply that knowledge in support
roles.
And then kind of growing up from there
into
OpenStack and Kubernetes
from, you know, along the career path from
canonical,
well, Dell Canonical, and Red Hat there.
And then since leaving those larger companies, kind
of carrying those skill sets around to a
couple of few different startups,
including some professional work, in the space,
which we're going to be playing in a
little bit today.
So
and then, like, now we're full on in,
like, the the coding world with Dagger
and, you know, other code powered IAC tools
and things like that. So
kind of getting further into,
like, software dev like ops
work, which
I feel like is a really cool progression,
and we're probably gonna see that more and
more as AI lowers the barrier to entry
there. And so,
hopefully, today helps, you know, other supercharge other
people along their
their trajectory as well.
Awesome. Yeah. You're right. We are totally in
the of as code. You know? I write
my infrastructure in Terraform CDK,
deploy it with Open Tofu, which I'm not
sure if I'm even legally allowed to do,
but, you know, screw it. And
we've no good Dagger for pipelines.
Like,
these days, you never have to leave your
code editor or your your language servers. Like,
everything is just right there.
I have gotten so attached to Versus Code,
and it
still feels wild to me that, like, Versus
Code and GitHub are Microsoft things, and I'm
in love with it somehow.
Yeah. It's a different world now than when
I entered the tech scene for sure.
Yeah. If you had to ask 20 year
old me if I'd be using Microsoft developer
tools, I'd be like, fuck no. And here
we are. I'm using Copilot. It's got everything.
Unbelievable.
But I that's a testament to Microsoft. Right?
They're they've changed their whole mentality. They're doing
good things, and they're helping developers. Like, I
have good nothing but good things to say
about Microsoft in twenty twenty plus. So Exactly.
Alright. Anyway, we're not here to talk about
Microsoft or AI or cool music.
We're here to do some Dagger stuff, and
we're gonna be doing some Dagger pipelines for
cargo. So can you tell us a little
bit about what cargo is?
Sure. Okay. So cargo,
not to be confused with the Argo CD
land stuff,
was named several years ago before those products
came out.
And,
it's,
named after the concept of an aircraft carrier,
if you will.
I think in in French, cargo actually is
a word, that they use for that sometimes.
And the concept is we're building a platform
that is from from the ground up, a
pass
that's built on Kubernetes,
can run containers,
virtual machines, the works. We're looking at Wasm
in the future as well because that's definitely
a really hot item that is proving
to be really valuable.
I'm I'm I'm looking for that whole road
map.
And right now,
the whole deployment of the project is either,
you know, manual CLI
or really
rudimentary
GitHub actions with a lot of, like, bash
run and stuff like that in there. So
kind of excited to see what the Dagger
spin on all of this looks like.
Yeah.
I am a little bit worried about this
one just because there's so much container stuff
going on, but we're gonna give it our
best shot and see what we can do
with this.
Just because
yeah. It's an interesting project to play with,
but there's been some really good improvements with
Dagger recently. And Markoff,
one of the Dagger team members, has been
showing off how to run the KTS and
save up a Dagger pipeline and stuff like
that. So, like, if we need to hook
into any of that stuff, we're certainly gonna
go and grab those examples and steal them.
But
before we go to the code and share
my screen and all that, you mentioned that
you've got some GitHub actions. Right? I just
wanna understand
when we talk about Daggerizing a project, what
we're saying is
taking things that would typically live in a
Docker Compose dot YAML, a Just file, make
file, CI pipelines, whatever they're using, any task
associated with that
project or CI or CD or even local
development environments, we wanna be able to do
that as code. That's kind of what we
wanted to do today is cover a few
of those use cases, hopefully.
So beyond the GitHub actions and don't spend
too much time going into it because we
will look at the code in a minute.
But what else do we have? What kind
of tasks are you running with your day
to day working on Cargo?
Sure. I don't have CI tasks tests yet
on on this code base. I have some
in some related code bases that I intended
to pull in.
But, I mean, you're looking for being able
to
authenticate against your cluster.
In my case, that's actually a pretty weird
topology because I'm using
tallow stuff with Omni,
and it's all OIDC
powered. So
I don't even use my local network when
I'm in my IDE. I'm all working in
code spaces in the cloud, you know, a
VM somewhere in Azure.
We need all of that to work out
really well here. I'm not entirely sure how
we're going to set up the authentication
within
Dagger. I know that it's a few fairly
simple commands on the CLI, so worst case
scenario,
we can shell out.
But I definitely
have
a number of questions there myself that we're
just kinda kinda gonna unwrap and uncover.
Wow. Talk about striking fear to me. I
mean, normally on Rawkode Live, I just sit
here like this and go, yeah, show me
a cool check. And now today, I need
to type stuff. And you're mentioning OIDC and
Talos and Omni and I'm like, oh, fuck.
You
know what? I
for the record, I did not twist your
arm into this.
So I
this was voluntary,
and I I I'm not being
crazy or sadistic or anything here. Right? No.
I I I think we're gonna have some
fun, and we're gonna install some cool challenges
and have a look at Dagger and see
how we can use it. You know, we've
what we have is a a Python project,
and we can start to lay it in
our code or Dagger pipelines as Python, as
Go, as TypeScript, wherever we want, and we
can just see how far we can push
this thing.
So Yep. I think it's about time we
start taking a look at some code, don't
you? Yes. Let's dive in.
Ta ta da. Alright. So I have already
cloned the project. I have made a couple
of changes just because of my very weird
setup. I do run XOS, so I've had
to modify your ENVRC
and add a dev env environment just to
get Python to exist
in this thing. Yep. So I'm only going
to run a dev env share. I
use dev containers for all of this, which
supplies a a lot of the same tooling.
So if
we're if we're hunting around for environment and
integration,
there's
a big difference between how you're approaching it
and my go to. But that should actually
be a neat way to really actually understand
what's in the black box instead of
just blindly running from a prepackaged starting line.
Yeah. I'm I'm trying not to go straight
into containers because Dagger itself
uses BuildKit. So I'm not sure. Yeah. So
for for the container, the dev container that
I run, like I routinely run Docker commands
with it. I use kind Kubernetes for a
lot of the in development testing, things like
that.
So it's it's it's fully compatible and supports
that
Docker CLI from within the container itself.
I ran a couple Dagger commands
and
just kinda like the hello world stuff, which
is obviously not highly complex.
And things went well so far.
Conductor is that dev container. It also
is what I use to maintain Conductor. So
it's literally maintaining Conductor in Conductor.
So I think we should be have the
freedom to do all of that if we
need to go there. But I'm also really
curious how you set up all the the
I used her end and you added
some extra stuff. So I'm gonna
enjoy how that's all tied together. Yeah.
I only added one line, which is just
this path ad
Oh, okay. Which you see me tweet about
earlier because I it was infuriating
that this is a different mackerel.
So are both are both of those actual
functions or is it just
camel case
syntax?
Yeah. Path add lowercase is when you want
to specify a variable name. So maybe you've
got like an old path and then you
can add stuff to it. Wow.
That's
That is
not intuitive
at all.
No. I lost an hour on that. I
don't know if I would have figured it
out that fast. Bravo.
Yeah. So that's all I did. And that's
just because I have Dagger locally again, and
Dagger's not available in the next package repository,
and this is next to us. So it's
very hard for me to escape next, but
the dev container is there.
So if we need to open it, we
will. But let's just try and get things
started
and take it from there. So You're warming
up. I'm gonna read through we got a
bunch of hellos here. So we've got Ravi
from San Diego. We've got Marcos from Uruguay,
Pat, Felipe,
Jeremy, Sam, Russell. Hello, all of you.
Yeah. Oh, there's Marcos who I was talking
about as well. So, hey, thank you for
joining. That means we've got help when we
need it.
We can proceed with confidence.
And some Dagger team as well. Awesome. Hello,
everybody.
My voice level is low. Yeah. I'll turn
that up a bit. Hopefully, that helps.
Yeah. Russell says your bamboo print screens are
awesome. Yeah. They are awesome. I was enjoying
that. Was a lot of fun. It was
a desperate attempt to hide a bunch of
stuff when I was rearranging things in the
house one day, and then I was like,
I'm just keeping this. This is great.
Alright. There is all the hellos. Thank you
all for joining us,
and definitely glad to see some Dagger folks
in case the help is needed.
So
let's see. Now, you do have a make
file.
I I do. It is
It's gnarly.
It is not well maintained right now because
the project during the refactor has changed a
lot. So I was gonna wait for the
refactor
to kinda
tidy up and then
double check to make file, and I'm kinda
tempted to go into task files anyway.
But tell me, like, with the Dagger stuff,
like,
does Dagger end up replacing a lot of
the logic that I have to
painfully write in this makefile syntax?
Or what is the op what are our
options there?
Yeah. I mean, I found with my own
repositories and adopting Dagger,
I I don't even need just files, make
files. I'm not writing Bash scripts anymore. I'm
pretty much just writing
a Dagger task for everything because the nice
thing about it is is cached exceptionally well
at BuildKit via inputs and outputs, you know,
like, caching in any system.
Then they're composable. So, like, you know, dependencies
across tasks are very easy to tie together
because it's just a function call at the
end of the day. So applying that methodology
to my pipelines is really hard to go
backwards. And I started with repository to have
a just file,
but that's just because I've not got the
time to sit down and write more Dagger
right now. But I the more I write,
the the happier I get for sure. Well,
I mean, you mentioned Makefiles and the Bash
scripts. And one of the reasons that those
two go together so strongly is Makefiles have
very limited ability to maintain just
inputs and outputs from different tasks in a
make file. So that becomes like really really
difficult if you have to pass an output
into something so that you're dynamically assembling
the whole project.
So, yeah, I'm I I have I have
high hopes here that this will merge into
the product project and and and be a
a long lived bit of code. Yeah. Plus,
you also get to say goodbye to phony.
Like Oh my gosh.
I've had twenty odd years of phony. I'm
done with phony, so I don't want phony
anymore.
I I've had half that, and I'm still
ready to be done with it.
Alright. So you could that's wonderful help target.
And I think this would be the the
kind of starting point as we try to
work out what to start with first, what
to replace.
Yeah.
I think as far as the steps here,
the first thing we need to do is
figure out our authentication.
What we're doing in Cargo is using a
number of different cloud services.
At this point, it's starting to really add
up because
I am using Pulumi IAC for the project
at at the moment. I have secrets all
stored up in Pulumi.
I'm using
my Omni account over on the Sidero side
of the house,
and that's necessary for actually authenticating
to the Kubernetes API the way that I
use Talos.
And then now, if we're using Dagger, that
is another cloud account that we have to
authenticate against.
So I've
added
the token for Dagger to
my GitHub Actions environment
and my Codespaces environment.
So that authentication
should be an
environment variable, but I don't even know how
we go about just getting started to be
able to run those basic authentication
pieces if we wanna start there.
Yeah. Well, the Dagger token is 100% optional.
It's a value add with Dagger cloud. So
everything that we do, we're gonna start off
locally.
Okay. And then we'll start to work out
how we can bring in, you know, like,
spinning up a kind cluster for instance. Maybe
we can get that done.
For sure. Do you have any other tasks
that aren't
using for me in Telus?
Yeah. So
as far as the KIND testing goes,
we do have
support in the IAC for switching between KIND
and Talos. Both are a little bit different
in some of the components that they actually
roll out, how those variables
map.
So we can set
our
IAC config to include
that we are deploying the kind,
and then we just need to get the
kind cluster started.
I do have in the hack directory.
I have a kind config.
So if we want,
we can get that started.
The kind task in make file also creates
a couple of volumes that
the config mounts into
the kind cluster just for making it
easier to build and destroy kind clusters without
redownloading
tons of images every single cycle.
Mhmm.
So if we want to start there,
that is all local.
Okay.
Right.
So I'm I'm just trying to understand
the the flow here.
Yeah.
So you've got two different avenues when you
run your tests. One is against cloud infrastructure,
which Pulumi provisions, and the other is against
kind infrastructure,
which Pulumi provisions. Is that correct?
Kind infrastructure that the make file provisions.
Well, we provision kind, but does Pulumi still
deploy resources to that? Yes. Pulumi still deploys
to that based on the koop config.
Okay. Cool. Both paths work off of the
kube config locally. So
Yeah. So something we're gonna want to do
then is to
obviously get our Dagger
instantiated. Right? We need the boilerplate so we
can start putting things together.
We can then look at writing some Pulumi
tasks that can execute Pulumi commands. We'll start
with something really simple, which is just Pulumi
test dash version. Then we'll try and bring
in the cane component and see if we
can get Pulumi to actually run against that.
Now you mentioned secrets, which does have which
has me also a little bit worried. Do
we need secrets when working with the cane
setup?
You know what? I
don't
we do need to
open the
stack. Well, I mean, need to select the
stack that we're using. And Azure's in Pulumi
Cloud, is it?
My state is currently stored in Pulumi Cloud.
So Pulumi login and then Pulumi stack select
and kind create cluster. Those are the three
commands that we need to do before we
actually start deploying.
So can I let me just where's the
Pulumi code? Is that under no. Not stores.
Pulumi
directory.
I don't have a Pulumi directory.
What branch are we on?
You are on the reef the the ah,
actually, I don't have the right branch open
in my
Versus cup.
Hang on.
Git checkout.
Rawkode Dagger.
IO CICD.
Sweet. And the IAC is in the Pulumi
directory. Yeah. With the main dot py in
there. So if you look
I need to zoom in on the screen
a little bit, but I can see.
I've only got the main branch. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So, there's a branch specifically for
you in here.
I
don't know if you want
to
how you wanna carry over the environment stuff
that you've done so far.
It it'll be okay.
Okay. Let's be If you do
git branch dash a,
you can copy paste the name of your
branch over.
This one. Okay.
Yep. There it is.
Okay.
So stash
switch.
Nice stash too.
Yeah. Main on this project is currently
hugely
behind the refactor. That was just instantiating
all the pieces in the most rudimentary way
so that I could see what I needed
to turn in for common patterns and simplify.
And now I'm I I've been refactoring the
whole code base to
actually apply some consistent design and stuff like
that.
More reusable code,
modular, all that. Alright.
So
I think the problem is
where did we get that? Yeah.
And nothing is staged.
Why is this a new fail?
Doesn't
matter. Okay. Let's go back to the switch
command.
Stash.
Good. Switch.
Find my path add
and pop back over.
Pulumi directory right there. Uh-huh. Cool.
Yay. Okay.
Alright. So this is Pulumi config stack.
Mhmm.
Alright.
Yeah. And a lot of the logic in
this IAC is
targeted to be replaced with a Golang operator.
So
way more way more code to come in
the future.
Alright.
So
let's actually try and run a Dagger command.
What are we? Twenty five minutes in and
we haven't run a Dagger command.
We can do a hello world if you
want. Or
Well, when we set up Dagger, we have
to provide which SDK we want and where
we want it to live. So we can
keep it in a Dagger directory.
Now SDK wise,
you wanting Golang, TypeScript, Python? Yeah.
Let's go with let's go with Python. That
is the language you're using for this generation
of the project.
Yeah. Let's keep it consistent.
You've never seen me write Python. That's the
challenge.
We'll give that a moment. So let's just
create an all the the boilerplate that we
need.
So a little dagger in it here. We
have
the SDK.
We have
I'm guessing we're getting a new directory out
of this.
Yeah. It's gonna create a dagger directory with
our first kind of Dagger function, Dagger task,
which,
you know, we can start to make modifications
to it. We can drop in some Pulumi
containers.
We can run Pulumi commands,
and then we'll just tackle the problems one
at a time as we go.
Sure. But we now have an initialized module.
So what does that mean?
Well, the first thing we get is just
a Dagger dot JSON,
which just tells us where the Dagger code
lives, which is in the Dagger directory
and the SDK that we're using.
We pop this open.
We have our init dot py where
we have a container echo function and a
grep dir function.
So that is the first two functions that
we can run with the the Dagger CLI.
Okay. So that with exec there on line
is,
for example,
just
basically shelling out running a bash command. Right?
Yeah. And a and a container.
That's true. That is in a container.
So everything that Dagger does starts with a
from statement, just like a Docker file. Yeah.
We can run from Alpine. We can run
from Ubuntu. We can run from Nexus. We
can run from Python,
whatever you want.
We then
add mounted directories. We add caches. We add
working directories. We can execute one or more
commands.
And all we're doing is just building up
all the steps that we've been typically put
in a bash or a makefile.
We're doing them in a containerized environment where
we have very strong inputs and outputs. Right?
We know what goes into the container.
And Yeah. It's in content addressable and we
know what comes out and we can reference
things from containers,
move them around, and do the juggly dance
and all that without ever doing anything on
the phone. That juggly dance.
K.
What is Marcus saying?
If you're using Python, you'd want to do
Python
v n. I already have a VMs. I
set it up with
dev env. So Yeah.
We've have a local Python virtual environment with
UV, which is also installed also requirements.text
that are part of the project. So
I
don't think we'll need to specifically
get its own VM for for Dagger.
Although, you are saying to run that in
my Dagger directory.
So I am curious.
I'm guessing we're gonna be able to set
environment variables
in these containers.
And I wonder
since we can do mounted directories and all
of that, it should be
reasonable to assemble everything
so that credentials,
coop configs,
all of that manages to cross the boundary
into the Dagger
containers.
But it might be just a tad tedious.
I'm trying to think through how that's all
gonna go.
So there are ways to get secrets in
to our Dagger containers in a secure fashion.
Let let's just start making some progress. Right?
Let's let's see if we can run our
first Dagger function. Alright. So we got a
Dagger CLI.
From here, we can call functions. We can
list functions,
you know, everything that we need.
If we do functions,
it does container
stuff, and then it should give us a
list of functions.
Marco says my editor seems happy. It's a
little bit happy. It's obviously it's not picking
up the DAG, so you're we may need
to do a virtual environment just for this,
but let's wait and see for now.
So this
this is what's kinda cool about Dagger is
that everything in our function here,
like, Dagger can run functions in any language.
So you can have functions in Python, we
could have some in Go, we could have
some in TypeScript,
It puts all into the container, builds it,
and then gives us access to it. So
now we could do Dagger call.
We could say container echo.
And it wants a string argument, so we'll
just say
Rawkode.
Well, I think I need to do dash
dash string. Alright.
Yeah.
Add string
back.
And you can see here that it's doing
our container echo
and,
I don't see my echo, but it it
ran. I'm happy with it. Cargo container echo
string Rawkode.
Yeah.
Levison.
Okay. So pip install dash e SDK.
Alright. We'll get to that. I mean, the
Dagger pipelines are running right now. Our editor
experience might not be ideal,
but we'll tell you up as we go.
Now
let's just make sure that
you're you're happy with what's actually happening here.
So I wanna just make sure
that we can tweak this, you can understand
what's happening. I'll take any questions along the
way. If anyone watching
has questions, fire away.
So the other thing we can do here
is we're just pulling our container echo is
just pulling from Alpine latest. Right? But we
could do Ubuntu
twenty two zero four because nobody ever updates
beyond that. Right?
So I'm curious if we want to do
that or if we want to do use
the conductor container that's specifically built for the
project that does have all of the dependencies
that might kind of speed us along.
Oh, I was just gonna make a change
to show you it. But you're right. Yeah.
We should be using Conductor too. Okay. But
I just wanna you know, we've got Ubuntu,
and I'm changing the command to apt. So
if we run this again,
apt raw code isn't gonna do anything, but
apt update
should be able to run some. Oh,
that's Dagger call lets you actually
append additional
command
arguments at that point? Because this one is
configured. This function has a string argument called
string arg.
Okay. So it it knows that it's looking
for
that argument.
Yeah. So there's our Cool. At update. Right?
Now if we change this to be at
trying to remember the Python underscores.
I usually do some TypeScript, so it's camel
case all the way, but we'll get there.
So we can change this to app command
now,
and let's
get standard out. We actually want to see
the output of this container. Oh, look at
that. Okay. So now string arg will fail.
It'll throw it into container and give us
an error message, but then we can add
the app command, and then we're starting to
piece together a function that does what we
wanted to do with the arguments that we
want and that makes sense from a consumer
point of view. So,
at command
update.
Fingers crossed. Looks good.
Should have picked a faster command, but still
I feel like Marcos is over here.
He's like the voice of Versus Code. He's
like, I'm
not happy.
This is your this is your code editor
speaking.
Alright.
Yes. Editor's not happy. Thank you, Marcus.
We're let's fix that now then. Now that
I've covered a little bit about how to
get started with Dagger and then Jean Luc
and C and website's looking good. Thanks, man.
Appreciate it. Yeah. That website's pretty cool. It's
it's like Yeah. It's making people feel really
insecure about my websites that are legitimately terrible.
Well, I mean, it's all a few months
ago. A website to me was, you know,
a white background with black text, but I'm
I'm learning. So
Lev earlier mentioned so let's go into our
Dagger directory. So this is his own Python
project. It was gonna show requirements dot lock
as py project. I'm not a Python person.
I'm really no idea what I'm doing.
I don't have pep.
So, Lev, based on your comment, you said
pep install dash e SDK.
Is that because the SDK has
its own requirements,
or am I installing that into my existing
VM? Do I need a new v n?
Maybe we should have used TypeScript.
Well, if I knew Python. Right? What what
would you do with a py project dot
toml?
Okay. So I I I I I I
know Python
in terms of IAC
and have not used pyproject toml configs
before.
Alright. So the blind are currently leading the
blind.
Okay. The SDK has the binding. So we
does that mean I can just go to
my requirements
dot text here? Can I just add a
local
Dagger?
Is that a thing?
I know that Not that I'm aware of,
but it would be cool if it was.
I'm waiting for a lever. Obviously, the Python
people are
not appreciating the genius that we bring.
Yeah.
I mean, I would love to do this
in Python for you, but I don't wanna
slow us down. I'm thinking maybe we should
go to a language that I'm comfortable with.
That's fine too.
If you wanna jump, if you wanna switch.
And then, I mean, when it comes to
transposing from one language to another, I just
need to see like the structure, what the
possibilities are, and then I can
transpose it myself later today.
Hey, it worked.
Holy cow.
I'm a genius.
You are. Clearly.
Twenty years paid off right in this moment.
You're done.
Retire.
Alright. Can I restart a pang a Python
language server? Of course, I can. Is it
gonna be happy?
Let's just pop it open again.
Happy.
Are you happy?
Yeah.
I I I've legitimately impressed right now. I'm
gonna have to like go back and watch
the recording
and I was here for the whole thing.
Alright.
So, I mean, that's my filled with my
standard out. So
let's
see.
Let's see if we can get that error
message again. So we run Dagger
call
container
echo.
That's interesting.
Oh, I haven't Okay.
Chat is blowing up over what you just
did right now.
Yeah.
I often say that the best developer experience
is one where you can be successful with
intuition rather than informed decisions. And that is
a key example of something that is a
good developer experience.
That I think that was the highlight of
the this livestream for me. Oh, we better
start to stop now. Right? Fuck it. Like,
we're done.
Quit on a high note.
Okay.
So now we need her at,
and
we'll do our updates.
I just want to see that So that
flag, explain the flag to me because I
wasn't actually expecting the flag to be apt
command.
That is that determined based on what you
call the argument in the code?
Yeah.
So there's a lot of
code generation happening behind the scenes here, a
lot of magic stuff. The way that Dagger
works is there's essentially build kit with a
GraphQL API in front of it. The GraphQL
API tells us, like, you know, container with
mount, blah blah blah, and they're nested all
the way down,
gets pretty gnarly.
But then they generate the SDKs on the
back of the GraphQL definition.
And and when we have a parameter to
a function, the name of that parameter becomes
a flag on the command line, and we
can also apply the types and stuff like
that. So you get all this.
There's the the they're
magical voodoo warriors. I don't know what they
do, but it works. I
I was impressed looking at the brochure
and and now I'm like, somebody needs to
rewrite the brochure because this is way better
than the brochure says it is.
Yeah. There's the and the pace they're moving
at is ridiculous as well. It's so much
cool stuff. Especially for the size, like,
Dagger team is. Like, the Right.
Impact per seat, they're killing it.
Yeah. We we need to stop catering to
their egos, We don't wanna, you know, let
them get too big.
So it's crap. I hate it. Why does
it all work? Fix it. I'm not getting
paid. So when I say things right now
about Dagger, it's legitimately just enthusiasm.
All of my enthusiasm is 100% legitimate. That's
for sure.
Right. Standard out. What's the error? Invalid selection
for command container echo response and query call
function.
Run
did not complete successfully.
That So this is this the return type
on this is it expects a container back
where it actually our standard out is returning
a string. A string. Yeah. So
if we modify this because who knew Python
could be typed in 2024?
Whatever.
So.
That yeah. That just was released as a
fairly new feature in Python. And I know
that
a lot of
early or bleeding edge type projects are still
working on adopting that. I wonder if Dagger's
already there.
Yeah. I mean, the type and stuff is
great. They're also, you know, using all of
these attribute annotation stuffs as well. It's all
very, very slick.
As you can see, we now get the
output.
So so that
is your first introduction to a Dagger function,
how we make changes.
Now we actually need to try and do
something useful.
So
next step.
I'm gonna get ready. Two minutes in. Let's
do something useful.
Don't tell people.
Alright.
So you were talking about conductor. There's a
conductor container.
Can you tell me a bit more about
that and how do we bring that into
this process? There is. I'm wondering, do I
actually get to write in chat or or
or am am I censored here?
There's a private chat between you and I.
If you wanna chat on YouTube, you have
to do that your your yourself. But you
can use Okay. Alright. So,
conductor container is the developer
environment for the project and the op operations
environment.
It has all the dependencies for
like Talos and Pulumi
and
Dagger
and all the Python bits and stuff like
that preconfigured
with durenf and nixes in there if you
use that yourself.
So I'm thinking that might be the easiest
container to run with. It's not small,
but no
mature Python container is.
So
it's g h c r dot I o
slash container craft slash conductor.
If we just wanna write that in.
With a k?
Uh-huh.
Yes, it Of course, because everything in Kubernetes
land has to start with a k. Right?
Like my name.
I started the trend Kubernetes just, you know,
got got there a little slow. Docs.
Alright. So we should be able to do
a dag
where we grab a container,
and it's ghcr.i0containercraft
Mhmm.
Call
it's
got it. Yeah.
Beautiful.
Copilot. Holy cow. Copilot. I love you. You're
recognizing my work.
No. Because I don't use the Python
language ever,
I've noticed that
it's from the keyword, so our function here
is actually from underscore.
Now you said this has got everything
in it. Right?
So that's the web exec
Pulumi
version,
and let's grab that standard out again just
so we can see that and update our
type.
Now what's cool here,
we've added a new Python function and annotated
it as a function.
The docs are our docs help string, which
we're gonna see in the CLI in a
moment.
And that's that's all we need to do
to register a new,
you know, like a make target or a
bash script of which you would typically do,
only we're doing it as a Dagger.
Sure. So the point now where if we
run Dagger functions, it should come back, rebuild
the SDK and all that and and build
kit, and then tell us that we have
this new function, and then we'll see my
horrendous documentation as a description for what that
task actually does.
Got it. The conductor container, again, is not
small. So do you have a solid download
pipe?
How big is that? Are we talking many
gig?
A few.
Yeah.
We may go a different route.
Because based based on what you're telling me
conductor does,
I actually think the need for conductor slowly
disappears
with the Dagger
approach.
You know, you don't need some monolithic be
interesting.
So
alright. Let's run our conductor function. So we're
gonna do a call
conductor.
Okay. We didn't add any parameters. This is
just gonna run. We should see the output
of Pulumi dash dash version as my connection
is able to handle the size of this
image.
Yeah. So
one thing that I'm curious about here,
we're running all of these different things in
containers.
And I know one of the plans is
to create a kind cluster.
How does that all work? Because I know
that kind results in, like, a kube config,
for example. So does that mean we have
to, like, volume mount the kube config
directory in so that it can write that
kube config and then we can carry it
on into other things? Or are we exporting
it as a string and carrying that around?
Or what's the plan?
So
this is where composition within Dagger becomes really
cool. So Okay.
What we're gonna do, we're gonna add some
more function. I'll I'll leave that pulling just
now. Right? But we'll do some other stuff
so we're not sat here in silence. Plus,
you asked a phenomenal question. So
let's have
I did ask a phenomenal question. Thank you
for recognizing it. Yeah. Of course.
I like to appreciate genius when I see
it. So
so I'm adding a new function. Right? And
we're gonna do this step by step as
if I was doing this in my own
project. And I'm not gonna pull this massive
image. Instead,
let's go back to that.
I'll paint later. Cat, find a better way.
And I'm gonna do a temp a b
c. Right? So the function is called touch
a b c, and we're creating a file
called a b c.
Right.
And we'll return this as a a Dagger
container
so that we can use it later on
as part of other pipelines, other functions, other
Interesting. Whatever. Okay.
Now here's where this is gonna is is
it gonna let me do two of these
at the same time?
Dagger
functions.
I like that spelling dagger.
Let's
see. Yeah. It looks like it's working, so
that's good.
My editor is happy, Marcos.
Well,
yeah, we have touch a b c. So
call
touch a b c.
Like so. And now this should be nice
and quick. There's no outputs. We're just returning
a container.
So blah blah blah. It's finished. There we
go. Perfect. So we have this container which
we can now use.
Yeah. My address? Now
we come along and go, know what? We
wanna do something here. So what I'm actually
gonna do is say, We we need a
new function.
We're gonna say read a b c. And
I know this is horribly horribly contrived.
No. I I this is the kind of
like iterative testing that I do when I'm
trying to understand something for the first time.
So you are perfectly in my lane for
how I learned. I appreciate this a lot.
Awesome.
And I'm gonna read it from a different
image. I'm not gonna use alpha
So we can do a web itching to
use that even to container.
Well, I've told it now. So, yeah, we
we're going through it. Now this isn't gonna
work just yet. Right? Because we have a
new base layer.
We haven't pulled down anything from anywhere else.
So let's run it and see that fail.
Yeah. Read
a b c.
And we'll check on
it's pulling.
Yep. It is.
My connection Codespaces
pulls the image pretty quick.
My connection is not gonna be fantastic when
I'm streaming, but we'll make it Right.
So now we get an error that fail
doesn't exist.
So what we could do here is you
can say, well, actually,
let's assign
horrible. I need a better name. I can't
do that. I can't do that to myself.
We'll just call this a t a b
c file
equals, and we're gonna do self touch a
b c. So we're gonna run that task.
Now these will be cached a lot because
Uh-huh. It's and puts and outputs with both
in in container. The same way a Dockerfile
works, so caching is very similar.
But we want to get a file from
this.
Okay.
And then
well, I mean, I could just write that
as is to the I I could just
take that and then print it, to be
honest. But we could mount it into this
other container.
So we could say with
file,
which needs a path and a source. So
I'm gonna put it in the same location,
and it is our a b c file,
like so.
I think I'm gonna now that we're doing
this part, I think I'm gonna have to
sleep on it for it to actually fully
sink in and then start thinking natively in
this paradigm.
Because that is a little bit, like
I mean, we're layering a lot of concepts
here. We're writing Python.
The Python runs a ton of stuff in
containers.
It's not normal Python because a ton of
things are happening in the background.
Like, there is a lot of
new neurons that you have to build in
your brain for this.
Yes.
Just a shame we don't have fourteen hours
otherwise.
We we just need to
Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm gonna be playing with
this after this because
it very
intriguing, and I'm so glad to have this
introduction
to it. I don't I think it would
have taken me a couple months to catch
up to this
No. We're gonna do something useful with this
repository.
But I'm I'm glad that we're we're we're
we're making progress. Right? Yeah. So let's let's
touch on the thing that your question there.
Our touch a b c returns a container.
Yes. This then becomes a variable
that we can just use. Right? You know,
if you think about
building a container image. Right? Mhmm. If you
want to get something out of it, it's
actually very difficult to do because you have
to, like, exec into it with a local
volume out and copy it across. I think
it's been a little bit easier now,
but it's been a pain point for many,
many years. With this a question that I
had that, like, Dagger container isn't a concept.
It's literally an OCI container.
And when you do Dagger, it just becomes
a variable that we can introspect. I can
request files, I can request directories, I can
run more commands inside that container, I can
do whatever I want. And then it inherits
the name of the function itself is what
I'm seeing.
Oh, I do understand that statement.
Dag container from with file and then you
have the temp a b c and wait.
I'm sorry. No. The self touch a b
c dot file.
That
is
named based off of the
line 39
def touch a b c. Right? Or am
I Yeah. So we're calling this function, which
gives us back a container. We're gonna inside
the container to get a file, and we're
just attaching it to this variable here. And
from there, I could write it to my
local host if I want. But instead,
what's more like that you know, if you
think about a workflow,
say with Pulumi. Right? You run a Pulumi
plan,
and you wanna see if that plan to
fail so that you can guarantee that's what
runs on your next apply.
If you do that in Dagger, you could
pull that file out and store it somewhere,
and then your next function, which runs a
Bloomie apply with Mount Nab plan and and
run against it. And that's what we're doing
here. We're saying grab this a b c.
Now we haven't written anything to it. We
could change us to be an echo with
a redirect or whatever.
Sure. But we just want it to exist
to a point where we can see the
empty output here. So we're reaching into a
container. We're saying, give me that file. I
want to use it in this other container,
and then it runs. Another thing we could
do here, actually, maybe this is gonna be
a bit.
Let's run this first, and then we'll modify
it in a slightly different way.
Yeah. I'm I'm sitting on, like, a dozen
questions that I'm not asking so that I
don't continue to derail us.
All questions are good questions. It's less code
I have to write in Python.
Right. It works. The whole time. It's a
feature. This is great. We have all these
text.
No. It doesn't really do anything useful. So
let's change this. Right? Now what we're gonna
do is I'll paint, and I need to
be careful here actually because
we've got a muscle and glibc thing if
I try to do a command from Alpine.
Instead,
let's grab
is there an Arch Linux image? Surely.
Yeah. There there must be. Right? Sure. Surely.
You're you're gonna do another intuitive thing here
and it's gonna work flawlessly.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna grab
gold one. What's the latest version of gold?
One one twenty seven?
No.
Seven or eight?
Go one. So
to the point where I'm gonna run Go
I'm on 1.21.
One two one. Right. Okay. I thought Yeah.
should work for Marcus. Okay. And we're gonna
run Go version here,
and we're gonna get back a container. But
what I'm actually gonna do what I'm actually
going to do,
we'll get the path for it so I
know where it lives. So I assume it's
gonna be used to bring Go. Yeah. So
let's
keep it more visual. Right? We wanna see
the version number. So let's grab the Go
binary,
which I believe is going to be here.
It may be wrong.
And we're gonna mount this in
to user
bin
Go
On the bin to a container, which has
no go.
And we're gonna run go version again.
Thing that I'm curious about here is you
could actually do which go and then use
that
output as a string to inform
the path that you
hard coded in on forty four and forty
five?
I totally could. Yes.
Okay.
Practicing
concepts here out loud.
Alright.
Let's get standardized first. One dot two doesn't
exist, so I think we need to drop
one dot two one. It looks like Marcos
is backing us up here.
Well, he says up for failure faster than
fixed it, so that's okay.
So let's run touch a b c.
Touch.
Hey. We've got conductor as well, so we
can make some progress on the the real
work.
But let's see the output of Go version,
and then we're gonna pull that binary out,
stick it into the Ubuntu container, and run
Go version again,
which I just think is very cool. Oh,
Go one doesn't exist.
Yeah.
You might
go latest.
I think go line. That's what it's gonna
be, isn't it?
Possibly.
Yeah. There we go. There it is.
You didn't catch that, Marcos. Come on.
Supposed to be a team.
He's not even here to defend himself, and
you're like
I know. He's trying to stick me on
one bookworm there. But, yeah, we're we're all
good.
He's also talking about really oh, I just
showed the wrong comment there. He's talking about
a really cool feature we could do with
Dagger. And, hopefully, we have time to get
into it. But we actually have the ability
to, like, go inside
of our build pipeline and debug things live.
I need to see that.
That is necessary for success.
Yeah. Debugging is a very important skill.
And that's one of the challenges You've
got Podman here. Are you Mhmm. Is Dagger
happy with Docker and Podman
interchangeably?
Like, is there anything unique there? You need
the alias. So under the hood,
at least when you run a Dagger in
it, when it creates that build kit engine,
the Dagger engine. I believe it does shell
out to to Docker to get that set
up. So I just have to alias that,
Podman to Docker for that to work. But
everything else is okay, and I do run
Podman
in compatibility mode with Docker. So I I
feel like our audience knows
as much, if not more than us right
now
because apparently,
they're telling us all they're speeding ahead
and and, like, answering
the stuff that we're gonna reveal here.
Right. Well, we got
oh, yeah. Because I didn't update my type.
I wonder if I can just leave that
off. No. Let's
be good citizens. Yeah. Think yeah.
And let's not fall back to the lazy
typing. Exactly.
Yes.
No. This should be pretty quick. It's just
regenerating the SDK because we changed the type.
And then we should see Go version one
twenty two. Perfect. Cool. Let's take off that
standard out.
Go back to a Dagger
container, which means that our second thing here
will work. If we returned a string, we
would no longer be able to query that
container itself,
which is when you really get into composition.
Right? This
is where I would just say, well, let's
have another function
where we say def touch a b c
output or something like that,
and that would just be returning
that. So now we have a new function
if we need to, but we always wanna
keep that container available for other things. The
good code hygiene becomes very important,
especially for composition. But let's not get too
too meta with the code right now.
So now we can do a read a
b c, which is going to execute Go
on an Ubuntu container, which has never seen
Go in its life.
Right.
Read a b c.
Does that make sense?
I know we're not really getting into anything
particularly useful,
but We are. Absolutely. I
mean, I know that
we
kind of suggested we would be doing
actual cargo
work here,
but
I feel like we both have to be
on the same page to actually make progress
there, and you are doing a phenomenal job
teaching.
Thank you.
So her container file failed. So that is
not the path of
Go.
So let's say, read Go or file. Let's
call it Witch Go,
where we're going to execute another command.
I love Copilot.
It's so good.
And
we'll run which go. And that will give
me the path for go, which will then
fix that main statement, and we'll see us
passing artifacts from job to job and a
code first fashion.
So it's user local go bingo.
I want the container to tell me. I
know. You're doing a brilliant job coding your
way to the and
I'm just like, docker run exec.
The Dagger team are yelling at me going,
just show terminal. And I'm like, yeah. But,
you know, composition
is important too. We wanna show people editors.
But, yeah, we should show terminal.
So let's just make sure we've put out
the right binary.
Let's go for read ABC, and then we
will use terminal.
So one of the nice things that I'm
seeing here about,
for example,
using the code itself to find the path
is
later on down the road, if you switch
out a container that has a different path,
that's just gonna, like, dynamically adjust itself, and
you don't have to go in and fix
a bunch of hard coded stuff. So that's
pretty cool all by itself.
Yeah.
I mean, that should have worked. I'm not
gonna fix that. I said, no. Just complete
it and the go route doesn't exist and
stuff.
We did get go into that container,
and it did attempt to run. To me,
that is good enough.
Okay.
So
let's do
terminal.
So when we have let's
this one returns a container. We have touch
a b c.
So if we do Dagger call, I will
look at the help here.
You'll see all of our functions, and we've
got all the parameters. Is terminal not documented?
Okay.
We'll go to touch a b c and
do
terminal.
Tribal knowledge.
So
what's actually happened here is that Dagger call
touch a b c returns a container.
So when we add terminal, that gives us
the ability to get a shell inside of
that returned container. If we return to anything
else,
it wouldn't happen.
So I wanna compare this to what I
have been using. I've been using
GitHub actions for a lot of my CICD,
and I use
Act CLI.
That's a little CLI that runs GitHub Actions
locally in a container.
When things go wrong and it's a very
long workflow,
you have to wait sometimes fifteen, twenty minutes
in between iterations to see if you actually
succeeded at fixing or enhancing
whatever you're doing correctly.
And it is not accessible for debugging.
So this actually lets you
jump into your pipeline at the point that
it's breaking and sort out the problems,
like,
hands on.
And
that is my style. Like, if I can't
get hands on with my own infrastructure
and
build and things like that, I feel
like my hands are tied.
I love this and I'm going to overuse
it and
that's so cool.
Yeah. I think, you know, the Dagger team
are using Dagger themselves, of course, and that
dog fitting comes a lot of strong developer
experience benefits with every release. Right? They're always
making things that little bit nicer, a little
bit easier.
Yep. But Marco says the problem with my
help was I needed the function first,
and that should have told me the terminal
extra.
Cool. You can actually run any of Dagger's
functions. So Got it. There is a lot
of help there to read and
I love that that generates all dynamically based
on your functions.
Yeah. It kind of insane.
Yeah. You can even retrieve the file. We
could do that just on the command line
if we wanted to. So Okay.
Okay.
I mean, I think that covers all of
the
the basics. Now there's a whole bunch of
other stuff that we're I mean, we've got
what? Twenty five minutes left of the time
that we can set aside for this. If
we can build the kind cluster,
then
that'll give me enough boilerplate to proceed from
there. And I'm I kind of have a
goal of seeing if I can get the
whole,
like,
build and deploy to run by, like, 01:00
my time. So that would give me something
like two and a half hours. So if
we can get a kind cluster built,
I can run with it from there solo.
Okay. So we're gonna have to work out
the container within the container part. So I'm
gonna ask Marcos, so I know he's been
doing the KCS stuff. I think it was
Marcos. Sorry, Marcos. I'm speaking
and assigning you something that you haven't done.
But let's get the the boilerplate for the
kind stuff working with your config.
And then, hopefully, Marcos can drop in some
context for how we make sure that that's
actually going to work. Sure. So So for
this, you might wanna open the makefile because
the makefile, I do use make kind
a lot.
And there's
a few commands in there.
Yep. There it is. Okay. So you're looking
at lines
one sixty three to one sixty six
is the important stuff.
Do we need the volumes?
If we comment out those volumes
from our
kind config,
then we don't. But as long as that's
the kind config, we do.
With Dagger, we wouldn't use Docker volumes.
We would use Dagger
volumes and put them into the containers as
required. Although then, they have to get in
propagated into.
Yeah. Let's yeah.
Let's work this out. So let's take a
look at your kind config first.
Mhmm. In the hack directory
because,
I mean, aptly named.
Yeah. That seems to be it's a ghost
thing. Right? The hack directory. It's it's never
something I've I've done a lot of, but
I know. I I I have them littered
around everywhere.
It's it's not it's probably not great hygiene.
Okay.
So
what do you use these mounts for? This
is just an image cache. Right? Yeah. I
I I was just using it to cache
images because it is a Kubernetes project with
a ton of different operators and helm charts
and things like that.
And building and destroying and building is a
lot
of work if
you're downloading images every single time.
So I was volume mounting
basically local file image caches so that it
can survive
multiple
cluster build and destroys.
Okay.
I'm gonna try something. Let's come back to
Kangen just a moment. Right? So I
don't know. Python, can I drop this down?
Is that valid Python? No.
You you should be able to do that
within
the
parentheses itself. So if you go yeah.
What? I have to do it that way?
Mhmm. Yeah. That would work.
But there must be a way for me
to do it. Wait.
Not that I know of.
Alright. We'll just deal with the really long
lanes.
What I wanna do is grab
says
kind will be a bit painful to make
work. So I'm really curious
how that really works out and
it requires Docker CLI. So I have Docker
CLI in the conductor container,
but actually running the conductor container
requires
a lot of extra flags and things that
I do have documented
if we want to figure that out. But
Well, was gonna try this first. Super pretty.
I was wondering if because if we can
get Dockerdams
to work, we could just stick say kind
go binary inside of that
from the kindest image and it should it
may work. So I'm gonna try if I
can see if I can run Docker hello
world
with Dines inside of our Dagger pipeline.
Okay. And see what happens. So
there's a lot of and see what happens
today. Apparently.
We are we are mastering the see what
happens today.
Yeah.
So let's see. I feel like we've been
like succeeding rather you've been succeeding
so well for an hour and ten minutes
now
and
we're gonna run out of luck at some
point.
We're really really
either that or you should go to a
casino after this if
if that's a thing you do.
Yeah. I'm not alone in casinos anymore.
Okay.
A
self imposed ban. They sell whiskey and they've
got poker. It's not it's not good.
They know that magic combination works.
Marco says, I may need privileged,
and he's got a point.
Mhmm.
Yeah. There's definitely some things.
Although that did say that it couldn't
get a socket.
And then that's just probably because I'm not
actually using Docker. Right?
Oh, yeah. Good god. We are, like, stacking
the unicorn,
yeah.
Is there a pod man
Oh my god.
Don't
Well, just
put my container around pod man
Podman.
Let's yeah. There is. Oh gosh.
The the
insanity inception going on at the moment.
I feel
like this is proof that the internet should
not work and somehow does.
So
Marco's saying we have to start that first.
So we have to start Docker daemon.
Hey, I've got an idea. Right. Right.
This is gonna be awesome. So
I hope.
David said, hey, I've got an idea.
So we need to start Docker d. Right?
And I spelled privilege wrong. Let's just ignore
that.
As a service,
This might be just absolutely crazy, but I'm
gonna go for it anyway.
Insane.
Create so Dagger has this other really cool
thing where you can run things as services,
and then you can launch other containers that
can then consume them and speak to them,
allowing you to replace Docker Compose.
Marcus is getting excited. Okay. Yeah. There's a
similar thing in GitHub Actions, of course, where
you can start, like, what if you need,
like, a database or something like that for
your pipeline to run,
it it it has the concept of starting
service
containers
as well.
So now we could see
we could just run down again. Only this
time, what we actually want to do is
a docker
run.
Ugh. I hate using that shorthand since that.
It bugs me. Container run
dash dash r m
a little world. Right? So that should give
us,
and we don't need the thing. Right? But
we have to tell it where that Docker
host is.
So if we do web environment variable,
Docker
host,
and then
we need to grab
the service endpoint by doing
self stock create endpoint.
Okay. And apparently, we're gonna need elevated Dagger
privileges on line 53.
Yeah. I'm gonna So I'm actually curious what
that
means. If that means, like, Dagger has pseudo
or something within our current environment.
What's
the Docker port?
Two.
Oh, come on. 2376?
That sounds right. Thank you.
I was hoping to drop in. Alright. That
should give us an endpoint. 75.
2 C 7 5. Alright.
Okay. So
this is gonna create a service running the
Docker daemon. We're then going to add an
environment variable, set in our Docker host to
that endpoint
and run
Docker.
And
I'm totally making up this up as I
go along. So I am gonna check the
chat to see.
Oh, okay. WebExec.
So the Docker d
needs some sort of parameter.
So let's just
and secure root capabilities.
Thank you.
And the one that we're setting here, so
we're not using positionals. It's just args. So
args,
and then we can also do in
true.
Is that right, Marcos?
Well, I mean, let's try it.
He can he can fix my terrible code
layer.
So now we should be able to run
create king cluster.
Dagger called create king cluster.
So now we're actually gonna see multiple containers
happening with our Dagger output here. So it's
gonna compile that, generate the new SDK because,
obviously, lots of things have changed.
And we should see it spin up that
service for us running Docker
d.
Oh, no.
Class.
So
we didn't get a string. We got something
else. What's the endpoint then?
What have I
what is a a coroutine?
Any any string.
Where do they go here? Is there, like,
a two string or something? Quotes.
Wait. Are we missing
wrap Oh, wait. Does this need to be
a string? Supposed to be a string? Ah,
okay. No. It's a nim. No. It's a
nim.
It's async. Oh, I don't know how to
do async await in Python. Can I just
do await?
And then set an async function. How do
you do async functions? Deaf async?
Nope.
Alright. Save us, chat.
Or
you might pull the away off of
I don't know. Deaf, async.
Oh, it's async deaf, not deaf async.
Yeah. Copilot's getting me there. Alright. Thank you,
chat and Copilot.
Sweet.
And then No errors.
Thank you,
Jeremy and Lev. I'll jump it in there.
Oh.
Alright.
So
Create kind cluster.
But I think I've got,
Yeah. That looks okay.
Redeemed endpoint.
From address.
Where's the standard out coming from? I don't
think we're oh, here.
Oh.
Oh, because we've got an async function there.
So we're gonna have to await this one
too. Right?
And he also said we may have to
make this one async. So let's just make
everything async. Right?
Should've used TypeScript.
Actually, I'm quite enjoying the pie. I mean,
I'm not enjoying these really long lines, and
I wish I knew how to format these.
I don't have a a Python form. Yeah.
I'm gonna I'm gonna get
really obsessive with formatting and
apply that on my own time. But
Alright. So
no
end point.
So that returns the service.
Oh, I'm gonna have to await await. Right?
Because we just made the other one async.
And then
await await.
I think async causes more problems than it's
solving.
Service can't be used in an area. Alright.
Okay. Which one are we? I'm gonna ask
you to retype now.
Endpoint.
So create things returns
a core routine. So we do have to
await this, and that's because we made this
one async. Right?
An endpoint returns one.
Let's see. Jeremy dropped an example.
Return that container Alpine directory
with exact bash.
Jeremy,
let's have a look.
I'm not sure what that
that doesn't solve our async thing. Right? Yeah.
It's not grokking with what's in my head
yet.
Oh, you're showing me the formatting thing. Right?
Right. Right. Okay.
Okay. Create was never awaited.
I do awaited.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, wait. Alright. What
we have here is a parenthesis problem.
Service can't be used. Right. I'm I Marco
says this doesn't need to be oh, let's
I think we're making this difficult for ourselves
now.
Create things is fine, and we just want
to await the endpoint.
Cool.
I mean, that shouldn't be needed. Right?
But I'm sure we tried this first. That
just that didn't work.
There's gotta be some prior art floating around
somewhere on creating a kind cluster with Dagger.
Oh. Look, things things and stuff.
So he I tried to speak to Docker
or Dain. That's amazing. But it says,
no such host.
So it got our endpoint. It resolved it
to an IP address and then failed.
Now this shouldn't just be
So there in something
in the Daggerverse specific for creating
cluster. Is this where we get to show
off some of the
ecosystem?
Yes.
And that looks like there's quite a few
parameters that we can run with. Oh,
yeah. I I'm being silly. We've created a
service, but we haven't given desk container access
to it.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, yeah. And we can alias it. We
can just call it down,
and then we provide the service, not the
endpoint.
Okay.
Like so.
They're trying to fix all my all my
bugs for me.
So here, we could do
two,
three was it seven five?
Yeah.
Alright. Let's give that a bash.
And you're right. There is the Daggerverse. We
should definitely take a look at that, but
I really wanna get this cluster working.
Really, really wanna get it working.
I
actually like this because it looks like
I I'm interested in deprecating the project support
for kind
in favor of
the equivalent with Talos where you're running Talos
either in containers or virtual machines locally.
And I'm seeing how
even though there's not like a built in
feature that plays completely nice with starting a
kind cluster locally without
like kube proxy and things like that so
that I can CI all of my Cilium
integration.
But I feel like Dagger
I thought we had it. I don't know.
Lets me cover those bases
and accommodate some of the conditions.
Sorry. I didn't mean to yell over you
there. No. You're fine. I excitement excitement is
always welcome.
Alright.
Let's go back to service
endpoint
four two three seven five. And this needs
a week.
So you wanted to have to get kind
and do it another way.
That's what you're saying before. I really interrupted
you. Sorry. It's yeah. It's gonna be the
the same the same thing.
Like, it's Kubernetes and Docker, but it's Talos
specifically.
And that will simplify my code base a
lot because right now, I'm accommodating
different,
like,
helm values and things like that depending
on
which Kubernetes
I'm targeting.
Nice.
Alright. Well, Marco says I was almost there,
but I need a web exposed port because
Dagger uses that for the health check. Alright.
So that's how it knows whether it's to
restart that service or not.
We'll get there.
I'm I really want to make this work
just
so that we have a very cool Kubernetes
cluster thing where you can start to then
experiment and play with. And I know you
said you were gonna maybe get rid of
King.
Well, it all of this will probably transpose
pretty closely to
the Talos version because again, it is Kubernetes
in Docker. It's just slightly different than Kine.
Alright. We only got four minutes to save
the world. I mean, create a kind cluster.
I'm missing a parameter for Docker d, aren't
I?
Let me pop open a
Docker d.
Cut the red wire.
Apparently, you need a config fail.
It
looks like Marcos is pointing out that we
need to set the address to,
like, zero zero zero zero would work.
Oh, thank you, Marcos.
Dash dash code.
Host. So
Is this the one?
I have hope.
Marco says it's the one. We will all
be wrong together. So
the service worked.
Yep.
Alias
as
d I n d exited.
We have response
from query input.
Blah.
Is that just my command did it wrong?
Let's get standard error. I think we're actually
getting a real error message from the docker
trying to execute that container.
This is when we could hit the terminal
command.
Yeah. Totally, actually.
Alright. Let's get in there. So
let's just return
a Dagger container. Now this should give us
a container
with the Docker CLI
and an environment variable pointing it to our
Docker
service.
I've never never used a terminal command with
back end services. So I'm assuming this is
just gonna work well.
Spoke too soon.
Why did we have to pick a difficult
starting line?
Yeah. I don't know why that one's failing.
You can blame me. And violation for command
terminal response. Oh,
actually, I I didn't even catch this and
I probably should have Marcos said we have
hosts. Plural? There we go.
Yeah. But I I I mean, I should
still got this. Given us a terminal.
Unless I mean, Docker wouldn't like a
flag that's not real.
It was the service was happy. It was
passing itself to said so. One
minute.
And I'm running terminal.
We were closer with hosts, aren't we?
Oh, it doesn't like the insecure access
right now.
Oh, it's working.
Holy
moly.
And I'm pulling the standard error.
Although, we'll now see that this should be
nice and quick because most of this is
gonna be cached.
Right on 06:30.
Right when we said we'd finish.
But we didn't really that will work.
Yeah. We didn't
we didn't do the things that we, you
know, we said we were going to do.
But I do think that we have hopefully
taken you on a bit of a Dagger
journey and showed you the power, flexibility
of having Will be the power.
All of this as code.
So I'm pretty chuffed with that. There we
go. Look at that. Holy cow.
We just spun up a cane cluster inside
of a dagger
function. Okay. This is this is like a
Internet high five here. Yes.
I'm
gonna leave you with that to play with
it. If you were to have to that.
Pick this back up in a few weeks
and then Yeah. Make make that next step
and to run-in the Pulumi as part and
provisioning to that kind cluster. Well, might be
that, like, I push this code a little
bit further because I'm very motivated to drop
that make file stuff and I have to
rewrite the make file or replace it before
I merge back in the main.
Yeah.
So it might be that I push this
a bit further
and then we just spend a while roasting
my Dagger code and you're like, Pat, how
much did you use ChatGPT
because you're looking like a trench coat right
now.
Alright. I am gonna get that pushed. We
will reconvene
once you've pushed it a little bit further
forward, and maybe what we'll do, depending on
how far you get, is we'll be looking
at refactoring. How do we clean it up?
How do we make it shareable? How do
we publish it to the Dagger first? Because
you know what? People are gonna want a
kind cluster in their Dagger pipeline. We can
share that. Absolutely. Awesome.
Thank you so much for your time today.
Thank you to everyone who watched. Any final
words before I say goodbye?
Bravo.
I I feel like that was a great
way to show off your skill and
do more than talking on a livestream.
So really, you you went in into it
with a lot of blind faith, and I
feel like you're coming out of it victorious.
So round of applause from everybody.
Thank
you so much. Alright. Thank you for having
chat soon. Yeah. Awesome. Speak to you soon.
Everyone else, have a wonderful day. We'll see
you all next time. Bye.
Rawkode.
Miss you for a little while. Never fear
the return. Rocket with a smile. Join the
crew again. Don't you take the fall. Stand
tall. Raise your voice. Let's conquer it out.